we're going back to the phones at 6 1 7
8 3 0 47 50 a lot of people who want to
get on let's go to our caller from the
785 area code which I believe is is that
Kansas 785 David it is but I promise I'm
not the Kansas troll ok good you scared
me for a second there
no no David my name is Mark I'm calling
from Kansas and real quick I got one
thing on kovat and one thing on media
literacy first thing do you think that
suicide rates are gonna skyrocket with
the increased isolation and the
loneliness and then also do you think
that we're going to see a rise in
domestic violence with people who live
in abusive households that are now going
to be in those households 24/7 instead
of having work or school to go to you
know I worry about all of those things I
do and I've not been you know there I
try to find a balance between I want to
if I can try to prevent a bad situation
I want to try to do it I also don't want
to put attention on on things that I may
be giving more attention than it than it
deserves but because you brought it up
I'm worried about both of those things
to be perfectly honest and I don't
really have and you know think the ideas
being floated around at least for the
loneliness are and and the depression
get in touch with people via technology
and so on and so forth but and is like
is that enough is that really a solution
I don't know so yes I'm worried about
both of those things all right and then
there was a very short time ago you
owned a YouTube clip I saw you said
something like I haven't been able to
refined it but it was when you were
talking about media literacy when you
were an adjunct professor it was like
some sort of like acronym oh yeah at
your head about fraud right primary
sources it's called cat did you go over
there real quick and write it down it's
CA PS caps like caps lock you know the
thing that trumpets turn on their
keyboard when they tweet ok caps
critically analyze primary sources
critically analyze
primary sources that's your Mead that's
your acronym for starting to be as more
responsible and savvy news consumer
critically analyze primary sources right
all right thanks a lot David all right
my friend great to hear from you always
always love hearing from Kansas even if
there's a risk that I'm picking up on
the Kansas troll